it's your dream scenario you've
developed an Android app that's so
compelling and so interesting that the
entire world wants to use it this thing
is sure gonna bring you fame and fortune
no no no no no no hold up pain yes but
fortune the money where's that's gonna
come from didn't think of that
dude acity offers a course built with
Google that teaches you about
monetization strategies for Android ads
learn to balance quick wins with good
business models that support long-term
revenue stream and the value that the
monetization model has for the user this
course is all about the money so what
are you waiting for get started now at
Udacity comm / Google